Mình có linh vi lắm, chứ thành người viên đối bán chứ vườn mặt chận tối phía nâm.
Nếu mi tạm thăm mời, sau hôn hai ngày lập viện,
là hội đại biểu tân có mặt chận tối phía nâm là thứ mời,
hiện khi hành ăn công trăm hà mi tư, hành ăn công trăm hà mi tư,
hành ăn công trăm hà mi chính đã học phía nếm mặt.
Rồi tối qua đề ăn nhân sự, phà hiếp tương cối bán chứ vườn mặt chận tối có phía nè,
khoá mời, có bôn trăm linh năm vệ, đàn chở thích bệ bì hay vị,
bán thương trực xói, có trụ thích không trinh chách bệ vị.
Nại hội đại hiệp thương, cửa bá xam chiếm bệ vị,
khăn xà ui bán chùi mặt chận tối có phía nâm khám mời,
đàn chúi, châu xuống này có hành thạm quanh linh,
khoá linh vi lắm, lâm mời sáng lập xa kènh quanh linh vi lắm,
khoá xong trofi, ai linh đại giệ chụ khối tiêu bảo tại ăn cố la.
Chứ sẽ bị bà chiếc xói đều kìp thương cối,
anh có linh cho biết, đây là một vinh sự lớn lòng bà bán thân ăn chứa tự bị đen.